The Trump White House
is panicking
as the midterm election results
get worse
and the Russia
investigation looms.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
It's not unusual to see turnover
in presidential administrations
after a midterm election,
but this White House
has already seen
an unprecedented level
of turnover
even before the elections,
and apparently
there's a lot more coming.
-President Trump
reportedly ready
to fire Homeland Security
Secretary Kirstjen Nielsen.
-NBC News is learning
that White House Chief of Staff
John Kelly might be leaving
the West Wing soon.
-Sarah Sanders, for example,
has been someone
who has been there actually
for quite some time
and might be headed out.
-Others rumored to be leaving
include Commerce Secretary
Wilbur Ross
and Interior Secretary
Ryan Zinke.
-Damn. Is there anyone left?
Trump is slowly turning
the White House
into the Overlook Hotel.
Pretty soon it'll just be Trump
in a ratty bathrobe
writing all over the walls.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
You can tell -- You can tell the
midterm results were way worse
for Republicans
than they initially let on
from the way they're behaving.
And the more results we get from
last week's midterm elections,
the clearer it is that this was
in fact a massive blue wave,
even though in the immediate
aftermath of the election,
Trump tried to make it sound
like all the candidates
he supported won.
-We saw the candidates
that I supported
achieve tremendous success
last night.
-Last night was not
an absolute victory for you.
-I'll be honest.
I thought it was a --
I thought it was a very close
to complete victory.
I think it was a great victory.
I'll be honest.
-I love that thing Trump does
where he, in real time,
talks himself into
bragging about something
he knows is a failure.
It's like
he's psyching himself up
to ask a girl to a school dance.
"I'm an okay-looking guy.
I mean, honestly, I'm handsome.
If I'm being honest,
I'm the most handsome man
who ever lived.
Okay, I'm ready.
Hello, cheerleader!"
[ Laughter ]
In reality, Trump intervened
in a series of races
where his candidates lost.
He campaigned repeatedly
in Montana
against Democratic Senator
Jon Tester, who won re-election,
and he flew to Nevada
to campaign for defeated
Senator Dean Heller,
where his main contribution
was coming up
with a super-dumb nickname
for Jacky Rosen,
Heller's Democratic opponent.
-I have to tell you. His
opponent wants to raise taxes.
[ Crowd boos ]
-And take our guns!
-She wants to raise taxes.
Think of it.
I mean, it's ridiculous.
Should I mention her name
or should I not?
Huh?
[ Crowd shouting and jeering ]
I have a great nickname for her,
actually, but I'm not gonna...
[ Laughter ]
[ Crowd shouting and jeering ]
No. We shouldn't do it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
All right. I won't do it.
Wacky Jacky.
-Ugh!
What a long wait
for a huge disappointment.
That's like waiting
for a kid to show you a dive.
"Okay.
Okay. We're all watching.
Yep! Yeah. We can see you, bud.
All right, bud, let's see it.
Any second, bud. Come on, now.
Oh, all right. Yeah.
Great dive, bud."
Although I do think if she
really wanted to troll Trump,
she should totally use that
as her official title.
That would make calling her
Senate office a lot more fun.
-Hello. You have reached the
office of Senator Wacky Jacky.
For constituent services,
press 1.
For legislation, press 2.
For wacky behavior including
goofs, gags, spoofs, pranks,
whimsy, wise cracks,
japes, jests,
horseplay,
and general tomfoolery,
press 3.
And to hear the sound of a fart,
press 4.
[ Beep ]
[ Flatulence ]
-And then, of course, Trump
also intervened in Arizona,
where he antagonized
Republican Senator Jeff Flake
and tried to force him
out of the race
by encouraging
a primary challenger.
In fact, Trump even bragged
that he was the reason
Flake chose to retire.
-We also had a staggering number
of House retirements.
So it's a little tough.
-You said that many of the
retirements that happened
in the House
made it very difficult --
-Many retirements, yeah.
-That made it very difficult
for you in this election cycle,
and that it was because
they were chairmanships
that were vacated,
but Jeff Flake wasn't
a chairman of a committee,
and Paul Ryan
also retired this cycle.
So, why do you think that is?
Whose fault is it that --
-In Jeff Flake's case,
it's me, pure and simple.
I retired him.
-Oh, my God.
He sounds like he's auditioning
for the role of a two-bit thug
on "Ray Donovan."
"What happened to Three Thumbs
Joey? Did he pay up?"
"Let's just say he didn't have
the cash, so I retired him."
But, hey, say what you will
about Trump.
When he intervenes in a race,
he gets the results he wants.
So, who's the new
Trump-friendly Republican
who replaced Flake
in the Senate?
-An historic victory
out of Arizona.
Democrat Kyrsten Sinema
prevailed over Republican
Martha McSally,
making her the first Democratic
senator elected by the state
in three decades.
-So Trump bragged about
getting a Republican to retire,
and then that Republican
was replaced by a Democrat
who is also the first
openly bisexual senator.
This is a case
where Trump's like a guy
who doesn't get along
with his buddy's girlfriend,
so he convinces him to dump her.
And then his buddy brings his
new girlfriend over for dinner,
and when Trump opens the door,
it's Hillary Clinton.
"Ha ha! Hello, Donald!
It's me, Hillary, and I'm
dating your new best friend!
Ha ha ha!"
So as the results get worse
for Republicans,
they're getting more desperate,
and they seem to be focusing
their desperation on Florida,
where governor and Senate
candidate Rick Scott
has been spreading
baseless conspiracy theories
about voter fraud
amid a recount there
in an incredibly tight race.
And now he and his lawyers
won't even say
that they'll accept the results
as legitimate if he loses.
-Every Floridian
should be concerned
there may be rampant fraud
happening
in Palm Beach
and Broward Counties.
Senator Nelson is clearly
trying to commit fraud
to try to win this election.
That's all this is.
-If, after the recount,
somehow --
and I know it's unlikely --
but somehow Bill Nelson
were to prevail,
would Rick Scott,
who is the governor right now,
certify that election?
And he wouldn't say yes.
So, you've had a night
to think about it.
So is the answer
this morning yes?
-Well, I'm also not going to
answer whether Rick Scott's
gonna win the Heisman Trophy,
because he's not.
-"And I'm also not going to
answer whether Rick Scott
escaped from the Bodies exhibit,
'cause he didn't."
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
So, Republicans
have been spreading lies
about nonexistent voter fraud
without any evidence,
and you'll never guess
who they're blaming
for that nonexistent
voter fraud.
-Rudy Giuliani is pointing
the blame at Hillary Clinton,
writing Hillary's lawyers trying
to steal Florida election.
They are still counting
or creating ballots
just in Democratic
Broward and Palm Beach.
-People should be suspicious
when Hillary Clinton's lawyer,
who paid for
Russian information,
is involved
in any election recount.
-And now they are finding votes.
And you have this guy Elias,
who represented Hillary Clinton
in a lot of very shady things.
-Here's really
something frightening.
The lawyer who's representing
Senator Nelson,
the Democrat incumbent,
his name is Marc Elias.
Does that sound familiar?
That's the same lawyer
Hillary Clinton hired
to get that Russian dossier
created two years ago.
-Oh, my God.
They talk about Hillary Clinton
like the Crypt Keeper teeing up
the next horror movie.
"Hello, boils and ghouls!
Here's a terrifying tale
that will send a shiver
down your spine!
The lawyer representing
Democrats in the Florida recount
worked for a firm that was
previously hired by...
Hillary Clinton!"
♪♪
[ Evil laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Why? Why is Trump freaking out?
Well, he's reportedly
getting nervous
because now that the elections
are over,
the special counsel
in the Russia investigation,
Robert Mueller,
can go back to indicting people
and writing his final report.
We've heard very little
from Mueller
over the past few months,
leading to speculation
over what his next move
might be.
-He knows that the midterm
elections are over,
and he knows the quiet time
that Mueller gave him
is now going to get loud.
-A lot of speculation
on Robert Mueller,
who has been quiet lately.
-Mueller has been very quiet.
-This has been a quiet time
for Robert Mueller.
-Because Robert Mueller
has been quiet,
we should assume that
he's been more busy than ever.
-If you're Donald Trump,
there's got to be
nothing more terrifying
than hearing that Robert Mueller
has been quiet.
This guy is a Marine.
He's probably spent
the last six months
sneaking closer and closer.
At this point,
he's probably in camouflage
that matches
the Oval Office drapes.
[ Laughter ]
For two years,
Trump has acted like a guy
who's afraid the walls
are closing in,
and that was when Republicans
were in charge of everything.
Now Democrats control the House,
and Mueller can make news again.
Although if Mueller ever issues
a public statement about Trump,
he'll probably just say...
-I retired him.
-This has been "A Closer Look."